thank you very much indeed that is that
is most kind and first of all let me let
me thank Yale University as ever Rick
Levin and and Martha and also
laura-leigh for all the fantastic where
they do the Yale fellows as well through
Michael Capello KPMG of course michael
hastings and also tim and trish thank
you so much for for what you have done
in helping put all this together and ce4
who are about to embark on major tasks
worldwide of interfaith action and I'm
delighted actually there are two
organisation Steinberg Faith Foundation
and ce4 are coming together and working
closely together and so there will be
gene and ruthyn in partnership together
which is a frightening prospect me to be
absolutely Frank but also an immensely
effective one I've got no doubt at all
it's the Irish blood in in in both of
them and I just like to say to
ambassador Bagley thank you so much for
coming on behalf of the State Department
them for telling us and what the vision
of the State Department is and how how
we can fit into that because that's you
know to have that that that weight and
that power behind the work we're doing
is is immensely important so thank you
so much for that and thank you also for
I remember well the time together in in
in Northern Ireland and also remember
and the people used to to say to me in
Northern Ireland bit like they do with
the israel-palestine issue now they'd
say it's nothing to do with religion you
know and I'd say wow it's a bit
unfortunate because they think it is
nice
cuz you're like a flea it seems to me
it's got something to do with it
somewhere and the reason I i started the
Tony Blair Faith Foundation and was
first of all because because I believe
that if you are not religiously literate
there you can't understand the world in
which we live and that is particularly
so in an era of globalization that is
pushing people together so when I was
growing out growing up as a child I
guess I didn't mean many people of a
different faith but today if you're
growing up in London you and we build a
different my kids do that people of
different faiths whole time so you need
to be you need to have an understanding
of other faiths in order to have an
understanding of the world that was the
first reading the second reason was
because I wanted faith to be seen for
what I think it is which is something
that is positive a force for progress a
force for reason and yet very often the
only picture presented the world was one
of conflict and division and
sectarianism so that's that's what we we
started and then I actually wanted the
foundation to focus though on on action
not on theology which is not a cell not
interested in theology as I am and most
people of faith are actually but I
thought the best way to have the
interfaith encounter was to have it
through action to or through specific
programs and then when we decided what
is it that the people of different
faiths could mobilize around then
obviously malaria for all the reasons
people have given is such an obvious
thing obvious because of the scale of
the problem obvious because it is
preventable obvious because the faith
communities can play a role in it and
what is very interesting about the
discussion that we've had in this this
day and a half is and actually the
degree of consensus in a way about how
you know what we need to do and how we
need to organize ourselves and and the
question now is really to turn that
interaction between government and the
faith-based or
and the donors into something that we
can as it were then implement and in a
different part of the work that I do
hello it's relevant to this actually I
have a program called the Africa
governance initiative and basically what
we do is we we sit alongside we've got
two governments we work with President
Kagame and Rwanda and President Koroma
and Sierra Leone and basically we build
capacity in those governments and we we
do it not just by teams of people who
helped build that capacity but I do it
as a political interaction as well since
the politics of matters and when I spoke
to Paul Kagame about this first he said
to me well let me let me show you
something first of all he took me into
his study and there was a gate line of
of books tomorrow via see reports and he
said to be here in the reports that have
been done and he said this is what I
don't want you to do and he said I don't
want you to do it for very simple reason
he said these reports incidentally are
absolutely brilliant he said and they
tell us exactly what to do but he said
actually what we really need is to be
told how to do it because we can't turn
those concepts into into action then
actually it's really going to be no use
for us at all so what we wanted to do I
think over this day and a half is try to
get to what it is that we we can do and
together incidentally government and
faith-based organizations in the fields
in which we're talking about could be
incredibly powerful I mean governments
have strengths and weaknesses
faith-based organizations likewise one
of the curious things I learnt in in
government was actually the limits to
government and government has heft and
it's God's power and it can often make
things happen that's the good news the
bad news from out government is that
very often its bureaucracy it's like a
creativity its inbuilt inertia mean that
it doesn't
so governments also can be very
reluctant sometimes to engage for some
of the reasons we were discussing
actually with with with any type of
outside organization because they fear
that they're going to yield power now
that can be for good reasons
incidentally because they want
accountability it can be for bad reasons
too because they just don't want to
share power and faith-based
organizations in my experience and
instantly I I'm just delighted with such
a high quality participation and I say
something which I don't mean it's a it's
a take this as a compliment right this
is a compliment because having gone into
the world of religion I go to many
different conferences with people
religion and I just said for my people
now great thing about this conference is
they all seem a saint be normal now this
may not be true instantly are on either
count but it's so you're concealing
extremely well but the point is that
actually what we've managed to do i
think is to see how it is possible
indeed to put government and faith-based
organizations together if we could find
the right matrix of of solutions to do
so of instruments of application of the
power of government and of the
faith-based organizations so how do we
how do we do it how do we do it I think
I'm really having been a government
speaking more from the point of view if
you like of a of a voluntary
organization of them in a sense of a
faith-based organization and my very
strong view having been in government
however is this government I mean patch
a the fact that ambassador Bagley is
here which is actually great and
important but government will often not
go on knock on people's doors so we are
actually going to have to go and make a
case to government now actually it may
be that government itself is beginning
to change in its
two tubes and which is why Elizabeth
some point was actually important and we
had a conference in London the day
before I came this was a little bit
Laden incoming with the Department of
International Development in the UK
which for the the first time brought
together the department and the world of
faith to talk specifically about faith
and development now this is this this
was believe me I was a quite an
important breakthrough and but it
indicates i think that the door may be
more open but even so i still think it's
important that we recognize that we're
going to have to go out there and make a
case and provide evidence and show that
if there are shortages of capacity we've
got some plans to plug those shortages
and deal with them so what is it that we
need to do because michael when he was
talking earlier said that it was
important them that at the end of it i
gave some some specifics i think he
mentioned a biblical seven which i've
taken rather literally but there it is
what is the first thing the first thing
is that we have got to advocate that is
the first essential point now we can do
this as the Tony Blair Faith Foundation
of course but we need support and help
and and we need also to be able to draw
on the expertise of the people who are
working in the field and and this is
because what we are doing now is
something rather different from what
faith-based organizations have tended to
do so far as the political leadership is
concerned up to now now you know or the
people who have been gauged in
faith-based activity you know that
faith-based organizations have been
doing a lot of this work over a long
period of time one way or another I mean
we want to scale up of course and all
the rest of it but it it for government
and many people in government it's
actually news that faith-based
organizations are moving from
painting as for example with Make
Poverty History tremendous campaign to
actually saying we will be in part the
instruments of delivering these
Millennium Development Goals on the
ground so this is a situation where
where we are going to have to realize
though there is an increased recognition
we've got to go out and advocate this
and say we want to be part of the
solution not million putting pressure on
you the policymakers to take the right
policy decisions but actually to do it
ourselves on the ground in conjunction
with you and in support of what you're
doing but nonetheless be positive actors
and it sometimes takes time for these
messages to get through so it's
important that the messages are repeated
but that is the first thing to be an
advocate the second thing is we have to
demonstrate I don't mean demonstrate out
on the street exactly by me demonstrate
in other words show that this there are
real things that can happen and real
interventions that make a difference I
mean that's why whether it's project
Musa or what is happening with the
Nigerian interfaith association or
what's happening in Ghana Botswana and
the countries where actual projects are
going on and incidentally in the in the
individual faith organizations already
doing work we have to be able to gather
that together and and demonstrate that
there is a real value added in having
faith based organizations and provide
that support that infrastructure those
networks on the ground and you know
there was talk early and let me instead
this point thank Ruth very much for what
she has done but also Charlotte from my
faith foundation who's done immense
amount of work in putting this
conference together
but Charlotte was just talking about the
need to show comparative advantage and
what we were thinking of now is that we
would actually follow up and with the
kind support of KPMG but also some of
the partner organizations here try to
make sure that we actually gather
together and materials and show
precisely what it is that faith-based
organizations are doing so if ourselves
in kpn GM said burn her up and others
are able to do this and we'll contact
people afterwards we may be able to put
together some something that is a report
that shows absolutely clearly what the
faith-based and community can do and how
well it can do it and which really
brings me to the the third thing which
is that it has to be organized I mean
when Tom said follow the money I mean
that is right not in the sense that the
money determines what we're going to do
but actually if we are if we are to make
sure that these interventions are
effective on the ground then we're going
to have to make sure that we are not
merely aligning ourselves with
government but also making sure that we
are lining ourselves with the funding
streams that are going to go into and
dealing with malaria out there in the
community I also think the position of
the World Bank is very very important
than this but also USAID and differed
other development agencies we have to be
in a position where we are able to make
sure that there is an organizational
structure that we can relate to that we
can feed into that we can work in
partnership with so that we are more
effective on the ground and this is
where the the what what sefa is doing in
in Nigeria I think is is is a
fundamental important
because if this is to be organized it's
got to be organized in different
directions as I say it's going to be
organized in relation to the funding in
relation to the donor community but it's
also the faith community is going to
organize itself effectively the faith
community doesn't organize itself
effectively then it makes it very hard
for government and and and donors and
the idea of the the starting with the
Nigerian Association is precisely in
order to make sure that we get the
faith's together so that there is an
organizational contact point and one
contact point for those external
organizations and the donors and the
government's to deal with if there isn't
that it will be politically just take it
from me a lot harder to get things done
there is no doubt about that in my mind
at all and the other thing however I
would say is important is that that
organizing should also be done back in
our own communities back in in if I may
call it in in the West I mean one of the
reasons we wanted our faith acts fellows
the young people to come back into the
faith communities here in the UK in and
Canada and in time there's no reason why
this shouldn't extend to other European
countries is because you know there is
also a tremendous network here of faith
organizations that can be mobilized that
can be used in support that and and that
of course can be a very powerful
advocacy voice so that's the third thing
to organize the fourth is to build the
capacity and I think this has to be a
short and long term and just to say this
German I've learned a lot from doing
this Africa governance initiative but
also from work I'm doing in the Middle
East in in in Palestine I mean I have
basically come to the conclusion that
there is no way that will ever be a
Palestinian state unless the capacity to
run that state has been built at the
same time as who you're negotiating its
existence and you know you cannot and
you cannot talk about a credible hell
care policy and dealing with malaria in
Africa unless you're going to build
capacity that's sustainable over the
long term now the faith community can
play a part in that actually in many
different ways not just as instruments
of action locally but actually to to
anchor changes in the way the health
care system work within the community in
a way that is sustainable because that
the faith community is there for a long
time but it does that capacities got to
be built it's got to be built short-term
if we're going to get results quickly
but it's got to be built for the long
term for sure over a significant period
of time the fifth thing is and this came
out of many of the contributions that
were made is that we'll have to set some
goals and we have to measure them I mean
this is you know sometimes people resent
this on behalf of government when
governments are always wanting me let me
stick up for governments for a moment
it's not not one of those popular things
to do in the world but you know people
often used to say to me when I was Prime
Minister particularly when you were
asking for money spent on public
services they would say look just give
us the money we'll get on with them
we'll do our best you know what is it
don't said we got it you got to produce
this amount and you've got to educate
this well or you've gotta you treat that
number of people and in the end of
course that can't work you've got to
have you've got to have a set of
measures and a set of objectives and
you've got to measure them and that's a
very simple reason that over time you're
more likely to be effective that way now
this can be done in all sorts of
different ways but my suggestion
actually is that in order to evaluate
our work and take it forward that we do
select a group of projects I mean and in
a sense these can be self selecting in a
way that doesn't matter but I think in
order to make the advocacy case we are
going to have to show very clearly that
there are projects where a faith-based
component has made an essential
difference
and that there are outcomes that they
were given and that were measured and
that were produced now I think then when
you come to people said what can we do
for 2010 my own view about that is given
the shortness of time and the difficulty
of this I think again we will be better
to take some established projects that
are going to work over that period of
time and have some clear goals and make
sure that they are met rather than
something that is I mean no doubt there
were all sorts of global targets that
the UN and others are working to but I
think for the faith-based organizations
keep it clear and simple and
communicable in the end because it's
based around a certain number of
projects we know that working we know
what they're doing and we're going to be
able to say at the end of a further
years work this is what has actually
happened the six thing is to communicate
what we're doing I mean communication I
think it was Elizabeth's old boss
President Clinton said to me you know in
an Information Age communication is half
of the battle and it's it's it's true
and the fact is faith-based
organizations in fact I would say the
world of faith as a whole is often not
very good at communicating what it's
doing and and yet it can be so proud of
much of what it is doing and and part of
the reason for that is that we've got to
and this is where we should use that the
different networks of mission oriented
media and so on in order to get across
this case and this is certainly
something that we can help and it would
be pleased to help in but if we're not
communicated it isn't happening I mean
my mile press secretary Alastair
Campbell and always what he always said
to me was look what people see of you on
the news at the end of the day is what
you've been doing and slightly
politically incorrect this but one of
the things that I mean doors the end as
Prime Minister threw all caution to the
winds but a beginning you know I used to
really
have to be very careful about what went
on the news that night and all the rest
of it and one of the great problems when
you you you are a western politician the
country light light light Britain is
that you are always greeting foreign
leaders on your doorstep and there's
cultural differences between the
different foreign leaders she's a
British very reserved we shake hands
yeah we all sort of buttoned up some
foreign leaders they like to hug you
give you a kiss or less sort of stuff
you know on the front doorstep of
Downing Street TV cameras there you know
we spent a lot of time trying to work
out how we can avoid these pictures that
but eh but anyway and I'll see used to
say to me sometimes at the end of the
day said you say he so what you've done
today I'd say actually we've been
working on education policy health care
we've actually go got some good law and
order measures together you so now you
know i don'ti of those things and I said
I mean it eased to me i'm doing those
things what you've been doing he's been
outside Downing Street getting kissed by
a bloke I was might say a foreign blow
so yeah if you don't you're not
communicating what you're doing you're
not doing it and i think that the faith
faith based organizations this is where
by collaborating and working together we
can start to promote some of the things
that are happening and we can also use
it matters that we use the examples in
each other speeches you know when
President Obama used the example of
Nigeria it helps me I mean it gives to
the salience that otherwise wouldn't
have the last point is this that it
should be interfaith which is not to say
that in each of our own face we're not
part of our own faith organization and
however much we collaborate with other
face we retain our own faith I'm a
Christian I'm not gonna become a Muslim
Muslim olajumoke I'm a Christian and so
on
but the important thing is that I think
this is far greater reach and far
greater power to persuade people to get
moving to get them acting to get them
changing the way they do things if it is
part of an interfaith project and so
it's not a struggle for supremacy I it's
an alliance for change I mean that is I
think what it's if it's going to be
powerful and come through and make a
difference it's it's got to be that and
one of the the great things I mean take
a saddle bags project and render for
example you know the idea that you you
you are open to those of other faiths
helping is is of itself it removes a lot
of problems and barriers and it it opens
a lot of doors and so that's you know I
think what we should be able to do
specifically in the short term is
collect some good material together that
will allow us actually to have some
evidence for the use in advocacy in the
longer term I think there are
partnerships here that we can and we can
use air and collaborate with in order to
make sure that we are making the case
we're demonstrating what works we're
actually organizing we're building the
capacity we're doing the things that I
think are necessary for us to succeed in
this area and it is I know Tim spoke
about this as being being a movement
that that's what it it feels like to me
now and it's it's hello some people here
have been working this field for a long
time it feels to me as if it's coming
together for the first time in a in a in
a more powerful an important way and I
the reason I think that this is this is
the right moment in time for this is
because it's the right moment of time
because one governments and actually do
understand not all governments but most
people working in government today do
understand that they need partners and
that civic society can often provide
partners in a way that no amount of
bureaucracy can through government and
there is a creativity in an energy of
government wants to get things done and
after all let's assume the best of both
government and people of faith that they
want to help people for government now
to draw upon their resource is important
so I think that's one reason why why
this is the right moment of time and I
think the second reason is actually I
think people of faith do find a common
cause with each other across the faith
divide in one thing the idea of faith to
be seen as positive I mean I find today
that if I meet someone else of I mean
maybe this is a European perspective but
if I meet somebody else of faith even if
they're not my faith that I feel like a
connection with them and because
obviously that is something that is that
grounds my life completely and obviously
does there's two and that gives you
strangely a point of connection but it
also because we feel that it the faith
and we know we see that faith does so
much that is is positive and yet so
little that is often apparent and the
thing that worries me about the world in
which we were which are our children are
growing up today is that I mean if the
picture that young people get of faith
is and simply how one of sectarianism or
violence or division
then they find it very hard to an ally
the the natural yearning for
spirituality which is within people and
i believe it is within people to what
they perceive is the world of organized
religion and faith and the fascinating
thing i mean i have one of the oddest
history holiday your reading list
because I i combine very light novels
with with really about theology and or
the history of religion actually which I
find really fascinating there right I
read a book about the the Old Testament
how it was you know that the history
behind the Old Testament how it
developed over time and so on and how
the various books were written and and
and all of this which I was
interspersing with with reading PG
Woodhouse which is society strange
combination I know and not not not a not
immediately obvious but but what was
fascinating was the constant desire of
the Jewish leaders and to bring their
people back to what their faith was
supposed to be about and so um there's a
strongly moment when I mean Moses was
not mentally the people in the promised
land but Joshua was and had to get out
and say in front of the people you know
this is the mode choose your God choose
your gob because this is the moment you
either choose your garden or you're
going to choose these idols and that's
the way you're going to go and but all
the way through was trying to bring
people back to what was the central
importance of their faith and then I
another book which was actually about
the history of the early church and how
interesting it was that as the early
church grew
and it was persecute persecuted and the
were martyrs and so on and an
extraordinary acts of devotion and
sacrifice and so on but then when it
became the official religion of the the
Roman Empire suddenly it became the
persecutors and then what actually
happened is that in the seventh century
when Islam began and the Prophet
Muhammad in fact the Christian Church
was so riven by schism and persecution
and division that I should there are
even Christian bishops that welcomed
Islam coming because they were fed up
with the way the Christians were
behaving and then I also the final part
i read was was a biography of the
Prophet written by an English guy based
on the original sources at the time in
the seventh century and what was
fascinating is then to look at that
statement which was a statement of
extraordinary progressive thought and
dynamism for his time and then to think
how completely warped and perverted some
of the acts that were done and they
attend done the name of Islam by people
who misuse its religion today but the
point is very simple than each and I
know more about the Abrahamic religions
I'm afraid than I do about Hinduism
Buddhism Sikhism alone they're very much
involved with our foundation but the
point is this at each point we are given
a reminder and a calling to go back to
what our face should be about and I
think at this moment in time in in this
particular era this
cause to help relieve human suffering
and save lives allied to our faith
across the faith divide would be such a
powerful signal and not just of the
world that we should be living in but of
what we should do to create it so and I
think this is a really really important
point a moment in time for us to realize
what our responsibilities are and what
our true vocation is as people of faith
and what our mission should be if we
want to show the people of the world
that the 21st century despite all the
great advances there will be should
nonetheless not just be a century of
material advance but spiritual advanced
also and I think if we are able to do
that through this campaign we will have
achieved something quite remarkable and
and quite essential thank